Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular Memory!
Today we’ll be learning about the molecular
interactions that stabilize secondary structure.
We’ll use the structure from last time.
These proteins interact to modulate the movement
of bacterial flagella.
And as an added bonus, they contain all the
basic secondary structure elements I want
to teach you about!
Load the structure as usual, 1A0o, and display
the sequence.
Now, color by secondary structure.
We’re going to keep coming back to this
view to explore the different types of secondary
structure in this model, so let’s save a
scene.
Scene dropdown menu, store, F1.
Right click on F1 and rename it.
I’ll call it overall.
We’ll explore an alpha helix first.
Let’s rotate and try to find the longest
one.
Maybe this one?
Click on a residue in the helix.
Notice how we see a highlight on the sequence
display, but the scroll bar is outside of
it.
Scroll until we can see the residue we’ve
selected.
Great, now let’s expand our selection by
clicking and dragging over the other residues
that make up this red colored helix.
Now, one of my favorite command combos.
Sele, H, unselected.
Then, rename the selection to helix to save
it.
Helices have distinct hydrogen bonding patterns
involving their backbone atoms, which PyMOL
calls the main chain.
We’ll need to see the oxygen and nitrogen
atoms to show this.
Let’s color the helix with CPK coloring
and show sticks.
I’m going to make sure my N terminus is
on top by clicking on the leftmost amino acid
in the sequence.
And center it.
All the backbone carbonyls—C double bond
O groups—now point downward.
They’ll hydrogen bond to a nitrogen atom
of another amino acid.
If it’s an alpha helix, the hydrogen bonding
will follow an i+4 pattern.
The means the residue closer to the N-terminus
hydrogen bonds to the residue that is four
positions away.
For example, if it’s residue 100, it will
H bond to residue 104.
Let’s add these backbone–backbone interactions.
Find, polar contacts, just intra main chain.
Ok, that’s more than expected, but it’s
hard to see anything at all.
Let’s start by hiding the cartoon.
Still pretty busy and overwhelming.
Since it’s only the main chain interactions
we’re looking for, let’s also hide the
amino acid side chains.
That’s better.
Now, let’s analyze a residue making only
one contact to determine the type of helix.
Click on the two interacting atoms, and the
residues will highlight in the sequence.
It’s K122 interacting with K126. 122 plus
4 is 126 so this is indeed an alpha helix.
We’re also just seeing some secondary close
contacts with all these lines.
Let’s produce an image that just shows only
the main stabilizing interaction for an alpha
helix.
Well, we don’t want all these secondary
measurements.
We can use the measurement wizard to pick
only the interactions we want to show.
In the dropdown menu: Wizard, measurement.
We can now trace over the vertically oriented
i+4 interactions.
When we deselect the main chain polar contacts,
we see the i+4 interactions we’ve measured.
If we measure the whole helix, there are going
to be a lot of measurements that fill up the
whole names panel.
We’ve got a couple options to neaten this
up.
You can group objects in the names panel.
So let’s take measure 1, A, group, new group.
Now let’s add measurement 2 and 3 to the
group.
Now, we can operate on the grouped objects
together.
Let’s recolor them.
There’s another way to achieve this that
I really like, but if you mis click you’ll
have to start over.
First let’s delete our grouped object.
Now, the purple parts of the measurement wizard
have built in menus.
Click on “create new object”, and change
this to “merge with previous”.
Now, I’ll start where we did before for
the first measurement.
Then, carefully rotate to capture the others.
Notice there’s just one measurement in the
names panel, and we’re adding to it.
Let’s rotate and try to measure them all.
Ok, I think we’ve got them!
Click done.
And now we have one clean object that I’ll
rename to “helix measure” . A lot of work
went into that rendering!
Let’s save a scene.
I’ll call my scene helix.
Now, let’s use the scene we saved before
to go back to the overall structure.
Reposition the structure to show one of the
sheets and save a quick scene.
The arrows that appear on sheets in PyMOL
point toward the C-terminus.
Notice the strands of the sheet run in opposite
directions.
Now, let’s compare this to the other sheet
in the structure.
They’re running in the same direction.
This type of beta sheet is called parallel.
Let’s go back to the first sheet using our
scene.
This one is called antiparallel—the “anti”
indicates the sheets are running in opposite
directions.
Let’s dig into these sheets to see what
this means structurally.
Click on one amino acid in it, and use that
to locate the strand in the sequence.
OK, the sheet we want is in Chain B. Select
all of the yellow amino acids by clicking
and dragging on them in the sequence.
Hide unselected, and then rename this selection
“anti”.
Show sticks, and color with CPK coloring.
When I try to move this, it’s a little wonky,
so let’s use the A button to center the
selection.
Notice where the side chains are relative
to the backbone atoms.
Then, hide the side chains and the cartoon.
Now find, polar contacts, just intra main
chain.
There they are!
Notice again these are between a carbonyl
oxygen and the NH of the backbone nitrogen.
We don’t see the interacting hydrogen atoms.
Go ahead and save a scene.
Onto the parallel sheet.
Return to our main scene and click on a residue
within it.
Find it in the sequence, and then select all
yellow residues in Chain A. Hide unselected,
save the selection by renaming it, and then
zoom.
Show sticks and apply CPK coloring.
Again, we’ll use polar contacts to show
the hydrogen bonds.
Actions, find, polar contacts, just intra
main chain.
Hide the side chains, and hide the cartoon.
Now, save a scene called parallel.
Using the stick rendering, the way we can
tell this is a parallel beta sheet is by examining
the amide linkages, also called peptide bonds
in a protein.
Look for the carbonyl on one strand, and find
the nitrogen directly bonded to it.
It’s on the left in this view.
Now, look at another chain.
This nitrogen is also on the left.
The nitrogens are on the same side of the
carbonyls, so the strands are running in the
same direction: this is a parallel beta sheet.
Return to the antiparallel scene now and repeat
this analysis.
On this strand that’s positioned near the
top, the nitrogen is to the right of the carbonyl.
On the next strand, here’s a carbonyl, and
the adjacent nitrogen is on the left.
The strands run in opposite directions in
this antiparallel beta sheet.
And that’s our lesson on measurement and
secondary structure!
I hope you learned something!